[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
áfrica siete días aquí en france 24 este
es un magacín informativo 100% dedicado
al continente africano mi nombre es
liliana valencia que damos una mirada en
profundidad los hechos de actualidad de
la semana en la cuna de la humanidad
cada 10 de mayo se conmemora el día de
la abolición de la esclavitud en francia
una fecha para recordar a las víctimas
de la trata esclavista y de la
colonización este año la fecha coincidió
con los 200 años de la muerte de
napoleón bonaparte quien reimplantó la
esclavitud en las colonias francesas en
territorio americano primer ministro de
túnez decretó una semana de
confinamiento en el país que se
encuentra al borde del colapso
hospitalario ante el aumento de casos de
ccoo y 19 esto cuando el mundo musulmán
vive los últimos días del mes sagrado
del ramadán reporteros sin fronteras y
el ministerio exteriores de francia
confirmaron la desaparición del
periodista francés olivier dunboa quien
había sido secuestrado por yihadistas en
la región de gao en el noreste de marjah
iniciamos entonces con la información
aquí en áfrica siete días recordando una
serie de fechas relacionadas con los
africanos y sus descendientes que se
celebran durante el mes de mayo veamos
el 5 de mayo es el día mundial del
patrimonio africano el 10 de mayo es el
día de la abolición de la esclavitud en
francia el 10 de mayo el día de la
afrovenezolanidad el 21 de mayo se
celebra el día de la afrocolombianidad y
también el día internacional de la
diversidad cultural el 25 de mayo una
fecha muy importante porque es el día de
áfrica y el 30 de mayo es el día
nacional de la etnia negra en panamá
pues justamente este 10 de mayo el
presidente francés emmanuel macro
encabezó la ceremonia en el día en que
el país galo conmemora la abolición de
la esclavitud el objetivo puede recordar
a las víctimas de la trata trasatlántica
en las antiguas colonias francesas desde
parís nos informó no esta periodista
natalia ruiz
aquí en los jardines de luxemburgo se
llevó a cabo una corta ceremonia cuando
se conmemora la abolición de la
esclavitud en la francia esto fue en
1848 sin embargo sólo desde hace seis
años se hace esta ceremonia de manera
como estuvo presente junto con varios de
sus ministros y autoridades locales él
no tomó la palabra prefirió dejar que
fueran estudiantes de colegio quienes se
hicieran las diferentes lecturas de
poemas hubo momentos también musicales y
uno de los momentos más emotivos fue la
lectura de un fragmento del discurso
pronunciado por el cristiano tuviera
ella es la diputada que hace exactamente
20 años pues se promovió la ley que hizo
que el estado francés reconociera la
esclavitud y la trata de personas como
crímenes de lesa humanidad una ley que
además ha permitido que la esclavitud y
este pasado colonial la franceses se ha
estudiado a profundidad en los colegios
pero también que ha abierto la puerta a
debate acerca de cómo reparar a las
víctimas
esclavitud a sus descendientes que ya
sea una reparación moral una reparación
simbólica pero incluso se habla de una
reparación financiera por otra parte
varios comentaban france24 entre ellos
la directora del instituto para la
memoria de la esclavitud pues que en
varios de los problemas que se están
viviendo en la sociedad actual francesa
provienen finalmente de la esclavitud
entre ellos el racismo y la
discriminación y es que este año la
conmemoración de la abolición de la
esclavitud en francia coincidió con los
200 años de la muerte de napoleón
bonaparte quien restauró la esclavitud
de las colonias francesas en américa
después de que esta inhumana práctica ya
había sido abolida esto con el objetivo
de reactivar la economía francesa y
explotar al máximo los recursos
naturales y humanos tanto sus colonias
en américa como en el continente
africano
3 de febrero de 1802 los barcos del
general víctor manuel el clan
desembarcan en santo domingo su cuñado
napoleón bonaparte primer cónsul le ha
dado órdenes muy claras retomar la
colonia francesa dirigida por tussam luv
hecho por que napoleón ha tomado una
decisión que pretende hacer cumplir
restablecer la esclavitud de las
colonias francesas era casi seguro que
tanto contó cómo llegara al poder había
un plan para restablecer el antiguo
sistema colonial es decir la esclavitud
la esclavitud fue abolida por la
convención de la revolución francesa en
1794 pero cuando napoleón bonaparte
llegó al poder tenía un objetivo
restaurar el imperio colonial francesa
en américa y explotar al máximo sus
recursos ya no lo vi hay un lobby y los
colonos los armadores sus comerciantes o
fabricantes que piensan que la vuelta a
la esclavitud significaría regreso de la
riqueza y la prosperidad en santo
domingo los combates continúan
jean-jacques dessalines sucesor de
tussam lo vio derrota a las tropas de
buena parte y funda haití
[Música]
este recuerdo grabado en el corazón la
cabeza y el alma de todos los haitianos
eso es lo que recuerdan de napoleón el
que quería restablecer la esclavitud y
contra el que las tropas de los que van
descalzos del santo domingo como se
llamaban a sí mismos tomaron las armas y
derrotaron a las tropas de la llibrería
wikileaks visión en 1802 otra colonia se
rebeló guadalupe pero aquí la revuelta
fracasó y la esclavitud se restableció
en la isla que sigue siendo un
departamento francés las conmemoraciones
del bicentenario de la muerte de
napoleón despiertan un recuerdo muy
doloroso
[Música]
hoy todos tenemos el deber de exigir la
rehabilitación de nuestros antepasados y
que se respeten nuestra historia que no
se reescriba la historia simplemente por
la gloria de un hombre y por sus leyes y
decretos de 1802 napoleón convirtió
francia en el único país del mundo en
haber restablecido la esclavitud después
de haberla abolido cambiamos de
información para hablar del coi 19 y
vamos a túnez donde ante el colapso
sanitario el primer ministro y sí sí sí
un confinamiento de una semana las
restricciones abarcarán las vacaciones
del eid al fitr la fiesta de fin del
ayuno del mes sagrado del ramadán con el
objetivo de asegurar el distanciamiento
social durante las festividades periodos
en los que se producen las mayores
aglomeraciones
es la peor crisis sanitaria en la
historia de túnez según el primer
ministro para frenar el repunte de la
pandemia
james y anunció el cierre de escuelas
negocios no esenciales y mezquitas las
aglomeraciones y los viajes
internacionales quedan prohibidos
restricciones que durarán una semana a
partir de este domingo lo que implica
confinamiento durante light
las instituciones sanitarias colapsarán
virly fighting y ese es un gran riesgo
que nos preocupa ver cuando veo a los
médicos al borde de la depresión me
angustio por el futuro
porque podríamos ya no tener a personas
que nos cuiden
las unidades de cuidados intensivos han
alcanzado su límite con más de 500
pacientes el oxígeno empieza a escasear
cada día muere un centenar de personas
por kobe 19 los hospitales improvisados
no han bastado para aplanar la curva de
contagios en túnez mejorar la situación
sanitaria también es crucial para que el
país norafricano pueda acoger a los
turistas a partir de junio un impulso
imprescindible para su economía que cayó
casi un 9% en 2020
a través de un vídeo que circula en
redes sociales el periodista francés
olivier dubois aseguró haber sido
secuestrado por yihadistas el pasado 8
de abril el hígado en el noreste de mali
reporteros sin fronteras y el ministerio
de exteriores de francia confirmaron la
desaparición del reportero
es una nueva víctima francesa de
secuestro en el sahel en un vídeo de 21
segundos publicado en redes sociales el
periodista olivier tuba dijo haber sido
secuestrado el 8 de abril en gao ciudad
del noreste de mali a manos del grupo
yihadista jnm ligado a al qaeda el
gobierno francés confirmó su
desaparición aunque evitó hablar de
secuestro y desde reporteros sin
fronteras pidieron trabajar para su
liberación
hacemos un llamado a las autoridades a
que hagan todo lo posible y pongan todos
los medios a disposición para intentar
asegurar su liberación y que eso ocurra
sin más demoras
[Música]
expertos en terrorismo aseguran que no
está claro si fue atraído con falsas
promesas
alguien le dijo que podría realizar una
entrevista con el comandante y hadise
está local de la región por eso fue a
gao así que no sabemos si fue arrastrado
allí por un grupo yihadista o por
secuestradores locales que luego lo
vendieron a un grupo yihadista porque
menos
ya digo el llamado grupo de apoyo al
islam y los musulmanes se formó en 2017
cuando cuatro grandes facciones
yihadistas se unificaron bajo la bandera
de al qaeda desde entonces se ha
afianzado en la región malí el sahel han
estado luchando para contraer la
insurgencia islamista que ha provocado
miles de muertos y cientos de miles de
desplazados allí los extranjeros se han
convertido en objetivos de secuestros
tuvo a es el último francés en ser
tomado como rehén por militantes de
yihadistas en mali desde la liberación
de la cooperante sofía y petrona en
octubre pasado casi cuatro años después
de su secuestro también en gao
continuamos en la república democrática
del congo porque presidente feliz si se
queda claro el estado de sitio en dos
provincias donde los actos violentos de
grupos armados son cada vez más
constantes la medida le al poder al
ejército para administrar la autoridad
en esos territorios mandatario anunció
que el objetivo es acabar con la
inseguridad implementando medidas
drásticas
era una decisión esperada luego de que
el presidente félix si se queda y
prometiera medidas radicales para frenar
los enfrentamientos y la inestabilidad
en el este de país entre ellas la
declaración del estado de sitio
implementado desde el viernes en la
noche para las provincias de ituri y
kivú del norte una decisión sin
precedentes que nunca se había tomado
durante los últimos meses estas dos
provincias han sido golpeadas por la
violencia de los grupos armados lo que
está impulsando una creciente crisis
humanitaria se cree que hay más de 100
grupos diferentes operando en la región
pero uno en particular centra la
atención del gobierno las fuerzas
democráticas aliadas integradas por
rebeldes islamistas de uganda los
militares creen que los extremistas han
matado a más de 1000 civiles en los
últimos seis meses el martes durante una
visita a parís el presidente si se queda
y pidió la ayuda de francia para
combatir a los rebeldes y no a un grupo
con tendencias islamista se ha creado
con discursos y métodos islamistas mist
de un método islamista
aquí está haciendo estragos entre
nuestra población mutilación cónclave y
ahora estoy más determinado que nunca a
erradicarlo
en cuento con el apoyo de francia de la
zona
en el terreno está la misión de la onu
para el mantenimiento de la paz pero
muchos residentes acusan a los cascos
azules de inacción especialmente al
enfrentar la violencia
los jóvenes se han manifestado mientras
que varios pueblos de kivú del norte han
sido paralizados por una huelga general
para protestar contra la creciente
inseguridad en la región
y finalizamos este capítulo de áfrica
siete días con un clásico de la cantante
maliense fatoumata diawara titulado
esclavas esto también a propósito de la
conmemoración de la abolición de la
esclavitud en francia en esta canción de
aguará alza su voz a favor de la
igualdad y en contra de aquellos que
esclavizaron y subordinaron a los
africanos y sus descendientes durante
más de cuatro siglos
así que analizamos este capítulo de
áfrica siete días pero ustedes pueden
continuar con más en nuestra página web
france24 puntocom para ampliar la
información de américa latina y el mundo
quédense con nosotros estos france24
[Música]
para mí
fabbiani
lavín
parís
la mayor
y más allá
a mamá
y ya le fin de definir
sabes
efe